data
40.
staple that's step three
so that's a great sign right there
stable step three everything is at
flight pressures or now the only thing
left joshua is that final status check
with the whole team
25 seconds status check
go atlas go centaur go lucy
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
zero
liftoff atlas v takes flight sending
lucy to uncover the fossils of our solar
tower system
rd180 propellant utilization has gone to
close with control
[Music]
the vehicle has begun to pitch yaw roll
maneuver
now 30 seconds into flight
vehicle is 0.6 miles in altitude
traveling at 939 miles per hour
[Music]
r180 performance continues to look good
at this time
engine pump speeds and injector
pressures are in family for this thrust
level
[Music]
atlas vehicle attitude remains stable at
this time attitude rates near zero and
all
in all axes
now at t plus 70 seconds into flight
vehicle is four miles an altitude point
two miles downrange distance traveling
at twelve hundred miles per hour
mark one alex is now supersonic
[Music]
vehicles now passing through max q
maximum dynamic pressure
the vehicle is now
slowing down
slightly r180 engine parameters continue
to look nominal after the prior
adjustment to the thrust level
approximately two minutes remain in the
atlas booster phase of flight
the atlas 5 rocket weighs now just one
half of what it did at launch running
propellant at a rate of 2 600 pounds per
second
vehicle's now executing closed steering
centaur 5 center reaction control system
is now pressurizing the flight levels
so beautiful launch sequence there we do
have another minute and a half or so to
go with the booster in operation uh
getting uh loose now just under three
minutes into flight
atlas is 33 miles in altitude 59 miles
downrange distance traveling at 5600
miles per hour
so lucy being lifted up out of the
atmosphere by the booster getting on its
way into a park orbit uh before we get
towards our first stage vehicle systems
are operating as expected at this time
future
future portions of the launch activity
we have the centaur multiple burns ahead
in spacecraft separation
and the big milestone we should see josh
coming up is booster engine cutoff which
would be the first stage cut off and
then state engine is now throttling to
maintain a constant 5g acceleration
limit
we're gonna see a few things happen
pretty rapidly the the booster will cut
off just after four minutes and then
within the next 15 seconds after that we
should see the atlas separate from the
centaur and then the centaur engine
ignite for its first burn
centaur has begun the boost phase
children sequence
and the rd 180 is now throttling to
maintain a constant 4.6 g acceleration
limit
boost phase till down sequence has
completed
and we have beco boost range and cutoff
and a successful stage separation event
so what you're seeing on screen is an
animation that's being driven by actual
telemetry
so we are watching these things uh in an
animation happen here but they're
happening in real time as well and
that's one we have the ignition for the
first burn
all right so there we go uh we should
see the fair the fairing jettison here
we have indications of good payload
and there we go
all right nick so that wraps up the the
first round of of major milestones here
uh still very much in the middle of
dynamic flight the q system on the rl10
is now in an open loop burn off mode to
burn off excess fuel in the early
portion of this burn
so walk us quickly through mick what are
we looking for in the next and this burn
in the next one so this burns going to
end with uh mikko uh getting uh
centaur and lucy into its park orbit
around earth and then we will then get
into mess two which will get us into
that transfer orbit getting lucy on its
way
awesome so that's going to do it for now
finishing up the initial launch
activities everything sounding like it's
going perfectly
daryl back to you thank you joshua and
mick a beautiful launch out here from
our vantage point incredible all right
lucy was built at the lockheed martin
facility in colorado before arriving at
the cape canaveral space force station
for launch engineers at lockheed's
waterton facility used lessons learned
from prior spacecraft like new horizons
and osiris-rex to build lucy and in july
lucy was packed up and flown on board a
united states air force c-17 cargo plane
from colorado to the launch and landing
facility runway at the kennedy space
center from there lucy was transported
to an astrotech space operations
processing facility in nearby titusville
for final preparations before liftoff
yeah just a few miles from here before
it was brought to the pad for more about
how lucy was built let's send it over to
nasa's megan cruz
hey daryl yeah right now i'm joined by
ari vogel he's the deep space
exploration director at lockheed martin
space how are you i'm doing wonderful
thanks so much for having me wasn't that
just a beautiful lodge what did you
think about that incredible you know
seeing it go over the clouds and
brighter brighten up the whole sky was
just fantastic yeah to see it rise over
the clouds because you know we lost it a
little bit because of some cloud
coverage but then it just rose out of it
it was so beautiful and you know i
really wanted to talk to you because you
your team at lockheed martin space knew
that you were going into a project that
would require you to develop a
spacecraft that would travel farther
than any other solar powered spacecraft
ever i mean was that intimidating you
know it was it was a really exciting
challenge to to solve right and
obviously the most prominent feature of
lucia's are big solar arrays each one is
about the length of a bus
and
you know what we did is we basically
just broke the problem down into smaller
pieces and then applied systems thinking
to make sure that the design trades we
were doing uh didn't impact or that we
fully understood the impacts for over
the 12 year mission
so you know being the farthest
solar powered spacecraft is certainly
something that was difficult to prepare
for
as is going to a record eight asteroids
in one mission
but that's why we have such a
comprehensive test like you fly program
at lockheed martin and we took it
through the ringer at our facility in
denver yeah and you did it all within 14
months that's during a pandemic that's
incredible can you talk to me about the
challenges of that
yeah you know it's it's really
awe-inspiring i mean to to be able to to
build a one one of a kind spacecraft
during normal circumstances is
incredible
and the team just really pulled together
didn't miss a beat connected and
collaborated you know made sure that we
didn't
didn't have any mistakes and it really
accelerated some of our digital
transformation initiatives too having to
to work during the pandemic
and not a single shift was missed during
integration and tests due to covet so
team just did an awesome job leadership
with the preparation and the over
communication and the transparency
and then all the team you know just
didn't let their commitment to lucy
waiver
and i think the thing that i'm most
proud about actually is is that through
it all we still continue to all of our
stem events all our mentoring our
coaching
lockheed martin nasa southwest research
institute
hundreds of thousands of hours
into that so it's really really a great
job and really quick you also built the
antenna that's on there that's going to
help us communicate with lucy can you
tell me a little bit about that yeah we
did a six and a half foot uh wide
antenna that we built main job is to is
to do the communication between the
spacecraft and um you know it's also
going to send back some of the first
images of the trojans so the whole team
is super excited for that absolutely
thank you so much aria i really
appreciate you being here today and for
bringing lucy to life so thank you
thanks for having me all right daryl
back to you all right thank you megan
and in case you're just joining us we
here at uh nasa are at the beginning of
lucy's 530 mile journey to the trojan
asteroids beyond the sun going to the
same orbit marie as jupiter that's right
it was a beautiful launch here we could
see it light up the water behind us and
we actually had a gator in the water
just behind us joining us to lift us
yeah
lucy is named after a skeleton fossil
more than 3 million years old lucy was
an early human ancestor and the trojan
asteroids are fossils too of how planets
were formed
beyond the asteroid belt are fossils of
planet formation known as the trojan
asteroids
these primitive bodies share jupiter's
orbit in two vast swarms leading and
trailing the planet
now nasa is preparing to visit seven
asteroids
[Music]
embarking on a 12-year odyssey that will
span jupiter's orbit
[Music]
one mission will explore these objects
for the first time
[Music]
lucy the first mission to the trojan
asteroids
and another special guest that we had
watching the launch from the atlas space
flight operations center was not under
none other than
nasa's associate administrator bob
cabana he is standing by with uh blair
allen of nasa edge um actually they're
telling me that we lost audio with that
group so we will we will come back to
that if we can but while they try to
work out their audio issues but daryl uh
you know we had we had a really
unmatched view of of launch here it was
just spectacular yeah it was incredible
because uh we're sitting you can't
really tell but this behind us is the
kennedy basin right the turn basin where
they brought in uh you know the space
shuttle uh main uh tank as well as just
recently uh the core stage for the
artemis rocket which is in uh the vab
right now getting stacked you're looking
at the flight of centaur and lucy we are
elm plus
11 minutes and 26 seconds as we cruise
along and we want to talk a little bit
now about the message that lucy is going
to be sending that's right lucy is
carrying something on board um aside
from her scientific instruments she's
got something a little more
philosophical there is actually a plaque
affixed to the side of the lucy
spacecraft and it contains quotes and
messages from artists poets and thought
leaders and the plaque is meant to serve
as a time capsule of sorts for our own
descendants you see after lucy's 12-year
mission is complete the spacecraft will
remain on a stable orbit traveling back
and forth between the earth and the
trojan asteroids for perhaps hundreds of
thousands of years and one day in the
distant future our descendants may be
able to retrieve lucy uh there it is
this the uh the plaque you can see on
the side of the spacecraft this was
before uh lucy was packed inside the
payload fairing uh but this is meant to
be uh a relic for our and for our
descendants uh of the early days of
humanity's exploration uh and when they
do they will see some great messages
we'll see those uh we'll talk more about
those in just a couple of minutes
oh we actually have we do have it um so
this is um a representation it's hidden
a little bit behind your computer daryl
oh
but this is the actual plaque on the
spacecraft is about a tenth of the size
of this so this is blown up yeah um but
it's got um a diagram on it this shows
the positions of the planets as they are
today on the day of the lucy launch
that's right and there are some great
quotes you mentioned some of the great
philosophers and
thought leaders over time down the
bottom left you can see
that one there is from albert einstein
the important thing is to never stop
questioning and then in the middle we've
got the beetles in fact every single
beetle is here including john lennon and
he says we'll all shine on like the moon
and the stars and the sun
and then
up here at the top
um actually right here on the far right
we've got amanda gorman who just came to
recent fame at the presidential
inauguration and she actually wrote this
poem specifically for lucy and there's a
great quote in here she says hope
implores us may ancient
um the ancient study and the
uncompromising core of us to keep rising
for an earth more than worth fighting
for great words from a young poet yes
she's a she's an amazing poet just blows
me away uh we are going to uh now get a
look at uh some more of the messages uh
that we intend to leave behind for our
descendants take a look
[Music]
so
and this is what i want to say
to people to beings to consciousness who
are so far away i can't even imagine
them to represent our culture
accurately we should include
hopelessness
risk-taking
the role of
fortune good or bad
to understand each desire has an edge
to know that we are responsible for the
lives we change
no faith comes without cost no one
believes without dying
there are no curses
only mirrors held up to the souls of
gods and mortals
[Music]
remember you are all people and all
people are you remember you are this
universe this universe is you
i would just
like to say that
this wonderful emissary to the trojan
asteroids is itself a message
lucy speaks for all that is best about
human
ingenuity
curiosity
and endeavor do you still have birds
that wake you up in the morning
with their singing and lovers
who gaze at the stars
trying to read in them
the fate of their love if you do
we'll recognize that
and receive those those words inscribed
on a plaque
from all of us
for all of us
filled with those
those aspirations and that inspiration
and that imagination that we need so
much right now
[Music]
a little noisy but i'm so excited lucy
is going back in the sky with diamonds
johnny will love that anyway
if you meet anyone up there lucy give
them peace of love for me
[Music]
all right we've got that audio issue
taken care of so we're going to go over
now to nasa edge's blair allen standing
by with bob cabana blair
thanks so much marie yeah sorry about
the technical difficulties you know the
uh the launch was so impressive even our
gear was affected uh but bob it's really
impressive to see this launch this
morning tell us how is it from your
perspective well first off from my
perspective i i got my very own nasa
edge microphone i'm just elated
nah blair you know anytime you see a
rocket ship leave planet earth it is an
experience it's a feast for the senses
sight sound and feel it's emotional and
heaven lucy on board i mean this is the
coolest darn mission going to the trojan
asteroids looking back at the beginning
of our universe five billion years ago
absolutely amazing and that's kind of
what's impressive i mean we're talking
about this important science mission but
here at kennedy we've had 24 launches so
far
what's going on well i i tell you first
off i could not be more proud of our
nasa team our contractor civil service
team that has persevered through this
pandemic not missing a beat you know
making all our missions i mean we've
launched humans to the international
space station for the first time since
the end of the shuttle program during it
we've launched perseverance to mars you
know we're getting ready to launch james
webb here in uh december that's going to
be amazing and and getting lucy off on
time you know we only if we didn't get
off in this launch window we're talking
another year before we launch yeah and
that is impressive to see how things
came together so perfectly but tell us a
little bit about what's coming down the
pike you've we've seen a lot of things
happen here at kennedy and lots of
things to look forward to well
absolutely you know i mean first off
from a science mission point of view uh
of course next month we're going out to
the west coast for dart then we're
coming back here in december for xp
in december down in french guyana we're
launching james webb what an amazing
telescope that's going to be a 21-foot
mirror you know and then a solar shield
a sun shield the size of a tennis court
you know they talk about the nine
minutes of terror landing on mars we're
talking four weeks and nile nail biting
as that thing unfolds but to look back
13 and a half billion years almost to
the beginning of our our universe you
know three and a half 350 million years
from the end it's going to be amazing
and then over in the vehicle assembly
building over there in high bay 3
stacked up is that awesome space launch
system that boeing core stage with the
northrop grumman solids and those four
aerojet rocketdyne rs25s the orion
spacecraft rolls over here in uh on the
19th stack down on top it's going out to
the pad for a wet dress rehearsal and
then we're going to launch it to the
moon we're going to do that first test
flight without crew in preparation for
going back to the moon in a sustainable
way so that we can go on to mars just so
much going on i love it thank you so
much for being on the show from center
director now to nasa administrator back
to you marie great things here at nasa
all right thank you blair one of the
asteroids lucy will visit uribetes has
already given researchers a recent
surprise revealed by the hubble space
telescope take a look
on january 9th 2020 nasa's lucy mission
team revealed that the spacecraft would
be visiting not seven asteroids as
planned but eight as it turns out
uribetes one of the trojan asteroids
along lucy's path has a small satellite
or moonlit orbiting it finding these
tiny new worlds before lucy is launched
in 2021 means that the team can
investigate their orbits and plan for
more detailed follow-up observations
during flybys
dr keith knull and other lucy science
team members have been using the hubble
space telescope to search for satellites
and rings around lucy's targets this can
be challenging since the raw images are
often filled with bumps blobs and
diffraction spikes the lucy team didn't
see any evidence of a new satellite
until november 2019
after experimenting with the brightness
and contrast on the hubble images dr
knoll saw a peculiar faint spot near the
much brighter uribetes dr mike brown
another team member noticed the spot
showed up in a slightly different
position on another set of hubble images
taken two days later
this change suggested that the spot was
an orbiting satellite the team went back
to hubble and got three more chances to
make observations of the possible new
satellite on the first two tries the
little moonlit was nowhere to be found
but on the third observation on january
3rd 2020
they found the possible new satellite
again
it was clearly visible next to eurivides
which was over six thousand times
brighter this huge difference in
brightness suggests that the satellite
is less than one kilometer in diameter
very small compared to urbities at 64
kilometers with a few more hubble
observations the team pinned down the
new satellite's orbit and they proposed
a name the international astronomical
unit approved and from now on the little
satellite will be known as quetza after
enriqueta basilio the first woman to
light the olympic cauldron evidence
indicates that the trojan asteroid
derivities is the largest fragment from
a massive asteroid collision that
happened billions of years ago it is
possible that the new satellite quetza
is a remnant of that catastrophic event
whether with hubble or if the lucy
spacecraft's flyby each observation
enriches our understanding about the
trojan asteroids formation and
eurobide's relationship with its newly
discovered companion the discovery of
this new moonlit around the trojan
asteroid uribetes is just a preview of
the incredible scientific knowledge that
will be captured by the lusi mission as
it explores this area of our solar
system
all right our our next guest is uh one
of the great minds behind the mighty
atlas 5 which just had another
spectacular launch here he's standing by
with franklin fitzgerald from nasa edge
over at the asoc franklin yeah thanks
marie i'm here with scott messer ula
program manager uh scott how did the
launch go from ula ula's perspective
well it was uh near perfect so far we we
never claim success until we separate
and get spacecraft where it wants to be
but so far the first stage was great the
countdown was very quiet and
it's a beautiful launch so far great
great to hear
this is a mission unlike any other
before can you tell us exactly how
unique the trajectory was for the atlas
v on this mission
yeah so certainly the trajectory for the
spacecraft is very unique
probably never been done before
but from an atlas standpoint we've
launched many planetary missions over
the years and
we just kind of did our standard thing
in order to get the spacecraft ready to
go
um you know getting ready for this
mission through covid uh was a challenge
for i know many people uh were there any
challenges that you had to overcome is
there any kind of anecdote that you can
tell about this mission
yeah so uh the team it's been a very uh
aggressive week a couple of weeks with
us you know we launched lance at uh nine
just a few weeks ago turned around uh
the end of the week so we launched on
monday and we turned around and had uh
the wet dress rehearsal here for lucy on
friday and uh
then turned around and did our vulcan
ptt test here so it's been really uh a
very exciting week for the team here and
the team has worked really hard through
all the covet stuff through all of the
activities uh
in order to maintain the launch date and
here we are right at the beginning of
the window and
a beautiful launch so far absolutely
well scott uh we wish you the best of
luck uh over the next 12 years and uh
thanks for joining us here on the show
today uh marie and daryl back to you to
learn more about science all right scott
and franklin thank you very much as you
look at the bottom of your screen want
to remind you we have a progress bar
which is tracking where we're going you
can see that we had the main engine cut
off we're awaiting that second burn of
the centaur and of course we'll have all
of that for you but we have about an
hour to go before signal acquisition
from lucy only then will the team be
able to breathe a sigh of relief so
let's hear from some of the scientists
about their passion for lucy in their
own words
hi my name is donya douglas bradshaw and
i'm the project manager for the lucy
project which will be the first mission
to the trojan asteroids building a
spacecraft is quite exciting i worked
many decades as a mechanical engineer
really focused on thermal and heat
transfer and so when you work in that
capacity you are supporting the
development of spacecraft as well as
instruments
hi my name is dr carly howitt and i am
the instrument scientist of the mvic
camera on lucy i love working on lucy
for so many reasons but one of them is
being able to explore the universe from
the comfort of my own office so i don't
have to don diving gear or you know go
into these dangerous or hard situations
i get to enjoy the data as it comes back
from the comfort of my office and
explore the universe that way my name is
corey prichal and i am the mechanical
operations lead for the interplanetary
spacecraft lucy
my job is to plan and lead major
mechanical operations such as spacecraft
transportations spacecraft crane lifts
or testing of major spacecraft
components and ensure they go off
without a hitch
[Music]
my name is mike secaric i'm the deputy
product system engineer for lucy the
thing i like the most about product
system engineering they get to touch all
aspects of the mission from the
spacecraft payload launch vehicle ground
system flight dynamics
private system engineers have oversight
of all of those different aspects of the
mission
i'm tiffany kapler i am a public
outreach specialist with the lucy
mission and one of the things that i
love about my job is that it gives me an
opportunity to use my creativity and
share my enthusiasm for science with
others while i get them excited about
space exploration
hi i'm rick berry and i am the
configuration management lead for the
lucy mission at goddard space flight
center we're building spacecraft we're
building
payloads and instruments at goddard we
coordinate with our team members to
ensure that the configuration management
is correct by managing the changes and
the requirements hello my name is
elizabeth mccall and i'm the project
support specialist for the lucy project
one of the more memorable experiences
i've had was just in july of this year i
was able to fly with the spacecraft from
colorado to florida on a c-17 my name is
vince elliott and i'm the lucy deputy
project manager over resources
i lead a team of 12 and they are
exceptional at what they do
it also means i get to work with some of
the brightest engineers and scientists
the world has ever known
doing something that i love
hi my name is james trayley and i'm a
producer and animator at nasa goddard
space flight center and i created the
video series you're currently watching
right now
i'm so excited to see lucy launch and i
can't wait to share the complex and
exciting discoveries that we make out
there at the trojans to you the public
through film and animation
go nasa go lucy
[Music]
this lucy mission is dedicated to a
number of team members at nasa and
united launch alliance some of them no
longer with us today
there are three dedications placed on
the side of the atlas v rocket the first
says lucy strong recognizing the team's
hard work throughout the covet 19
pandemic there it is we got a shot of it
before liftoff and the second is a
memorial to ula team members mark kaz
kazubowski and william billy joyner mark
was an accomplished engineer and
respected mentor during his 30-year
career he focused on launch vehicle
structures and integration he led the
structural design of the atlas 2 2as and
3 development programs mark was also a
family man reminding his team always to
take care of themselves and their
families
billy spent much of his 35-year career
at lockheed martin and ula he was an
accomplished technician who supported
critical payload processing for the
department of defense and nasa billy was
known for his diligence and
dependability contributing to the
successful launch of many historic
missions he was a great friend and
teammate to many
and finally a dedication in memory of
craig m whitaker his 40-year career
began as a student with the navy you can
see his name there also on the rocket
that led him to nasa where he was a
founding member of nasa's launch
services program in
1998. craig was instrumental in
developing and managing the program's
launch service contracts over many years
the final highlight of craig's career
was the award of the atlas v rocket for
the lucy mission
craig was a devoted family man a
respected leader and a humble public
servant and we are here with his son
craig whitaker's son jared whitaker
vehicle systems engineer who also works
just like his father did for nasa's
launch services program jared great to
have you here i appreciate it glad to be
here how was the launch how was the
experience being up there and watching
this rocket which had been dedicated to
your father
it was really
really great i mean i usually work on
the the missions and things and so
sitting on consoles so um it was really
great to be able to see it from this
vantage point out here at osb2 fantastic
fantastic view from up there and night
latches are always spectacular and so
just really really really enjoyed it
what did lsp mean to your father the
launch services program and then you
following in his footsteps
yeah so like um
lsp i think he really embodied a lot of
the things that lsp stands for like a
good family man as as
we said um
really dedicated to to the work
dedicated to his family and um always
curious always learning learning new
about science missions and things like
that um really really meant a lot to him
so i think he he definitely enjoyed his
20 plus years with lsp and his all his
time with nasa for sure and jared we
know your dad was one of the founding
members of lsp from its earliest days in
the 90s and now you work for the program
yourself i got to ask did his influence
kind of steer you in that direction oh
yeah i would say absolutely um yeah in
1998 i was i was only seven years old
and so every afternoon pick me up from
school or whatnot go home and over over
dinner we had conversations about what
the the last uh science mission was what
was coming up with lsp and so he always
encouraged me to do whatever i wanted
but i definitely enjoyed um
going into engineering
and i ended up coming to lsp i think in
my heart i always knew i was gonna i was
gonna end up with lsp and i'm very glad
i did and so i enjoyed the couple years
we got to work together and and share uh
more from the business side from him and
more from the engineering side for me it
was a nice uh give and take so really
enjoyed our time for sure yeah and glad
you got to actually enjoy it as a
spectator for a change instead of
working it was very relaxing it was nice
yeah great and
there was some overlap between you and
your father at lsp
yeah so i finished my master's
in mechanical engineering in 2015 and so
we worked together almost five years so
it was really nice like in the on some
afternoons like later in the week he'd
come by we were we're not morning people
so we'd come by in the afternoon and
chit chat about how things were going
and what our plans for the weekend were
so it's nice to just pass by him and and
kind of talk a little bit a little bit
of work a little bit of personal stuff
at the end of the day and it was it was
really enjoyable yeah
that's awesome yeah as a as a
non-morning person myself i used to
appreciate you getting up early with
that
it was well worth it well worth it thank
you so much jared thank you all thank
you all right thank you for being here
all right learning what an asteroid is
made of without coming into contact with
it takes the right scientific
instruments we'll talk about that in a
moment but first let's check in with
megan cruz on top of osb2 with another
program scientist megan
hey there daryl yeah now i have tom
stadler tom what did you think of the
launch today oh it was absolutely
beautiful i just couldn't couldn't hope
for a more spectacular launch yeah and
you know you're the program scientist on
this mission can you talk to us about
what that role entails uh sure i mean
all of our missions have program
scientists at headquarters we're the
main science advocate for the mission
and we also work with the mission teams
kind of as coaches to make sure that the
science ambitions that they have for the
mission fit with nasa processes gotcha
and we saw lucy lift off about 30
minutes ago can you talk to us about how
her three main instruments are going to
work together to study the trojans sure
so lucy has three main instruments
there's lori which is a high resolution
black and white camera la ralph that is
a spectroscopic camera and a test that
is a thermal imager like a no touch
thermometer and so we'll be able to get
detailed images of the landforms the
craters cliffs landslides anything else
that's been going on on the surfaces
ralph will be able to tell us about
compositions we'll get an indication of
the mineralogy the chemical composition
and
will tell us from the temperature
readings what's the texture of the
surface is it rocky is it sandy is it
gravely they're all work together to
tell us what's going on on these
asteroids wow without even landing on
them that's amazing and we know that
lucy was named after the lucy fossil the
lucy fossil was named after the beatles
song lucy in the sky with diamonds and
actually lucy actually has a diamond on
board can you talk to us about that it
does so the latest instrument that
touchless thermometer is uh is an
interferometer and people who are into
instrumentation know what that means but
in an interferometer you need to divide
the incoming light into two paths and so
you need a device an optical device
called a beam splitter and one of the
best ways to make a beam splitter is to
make it out of synthetic diamond so
there is a synthetic diamond not a
natural diamond it's a pretty big one i
understand it's about 20 carats which
would make a big make a good diamond
right
it's an industrial piece of piece of
synthetic diamond that's really
essential for getting these temperature
readings on the surface of the trojan
asteroids awesome and you're also the
program scientist for dart that's
scheduled to launch uh next month can
you tell us about that experiment i can
well dart dart like lucy is going to an
asteroid and that's where the similarity
ends because dart
lucy of course is going to the trojan
asteroids and the outer solar system and
dart is going to a near-earth asteroid
not so much with the intent of studying
it but to demonstrate that we have the
technological ability to be able to
deflect an asteroid if we're ever in a
situation where there's an asteroid on
collision course with earth there is not
one now no no no known asteroid is on a
collision course with earth and the
asteroid that we're going to collide
with deliberately with the dart
spacecraft is not a danger to earth and
there's nothing that we can do to make
it a danger to the earth but we're going
to test our ability to target an
asteroid to execute a kinetic impact
that is run a spacecraft into it and
then we're going to test the asteroids
response to that impact how much do we
move it by and how effective that will
be to protect earth in the future
sounds like a movie strange huh
no maybe not not with as dramatic as
sound a script as some of the past
movies but it'll be very exciting when
we execute the kinetic impact and then
get the data from ground-based
telescopes afterwards that tells us what
we actually accomplished all right tom
thank you so much i appreciate you being
here maureen back to you
all right thank you megan if you're just
joining us we had a spectacular launch
this morning in florida
nasa's lucy launched into the sky with a
diamond a pretty big one it sounds like
apparently about 36 minutes ago and the
spacecraft lifted off on a united launch
alliance atlas v rocket from space
launch complex 41 at cape canaveral
space force station that was at 5 34 a.m
eastern time and in just a little bit we
expect to hear confirmation of
spacecraft separation and there's a
replay of the launch from this morning a
beautiful shot there as you see the
atlas 5 launching away from space launch
complex 41 here at the cape canaveral
space force station it was a beautiful
launch and every launch is always a
little different right we had some
clouds up high and it went behind them
and then popped back out yeah i love
that i love i love when it illuminates
the clouds because you don't i mean it's
it's pitch dark behind us now and so you
don't even know they're there and the
rocket just lights up the entire sky and
it's stunning it's like a sunrise
wonderful all right the lucy spacecraft
named after the early human fossil and
the famous beatles song is just
beginning a 12-year mission to uncover
the mysteries of our outer solar system
lucy shows us more
lucy's long journey to space begins
today but her story actually started
years ago
it took a team of scientists and
engineers many years to plan where lucy
would go and what she would have to do
then lucy's engineers had to build her
out of individual parts and put her
together like a puzzle
lucy had to go through tough physical
tests to prove she was mission ready
how are you holding up lucy
these are the vibration and acoustic
tests to make sure that lucy won't lose
any screws during the shaky launch on a
rocket lucy wasn't quite ready just yet
the engineers still had to be sure that
she was prepared for the harsh
environment of space
they chilled lucy to freezing
temperatures then warmed her up to
scalding hot temperatures in the thermal
vacuum test sure those tests weren't
easy but they prepared lucy for the long
adventure ahead
[Music]
so
we're glad you can join lucy on her
adventure to explore the trojan
asteroids
now let's get the journey started
i'm really starting to love that cartoon
lucy yeah she's great really cute thank
you lucy let's send it over now to megan
she is with the paleoanthropologist who
discovered the lucy fossil in 1974.
megan yeah daryl what an honor to have
donald johansen here with me today good
morning to you good morning to you you
know you have to take me back to that
day when you discovered lucy in ethiopia
back in 1974 tell me how you found her
well it's amazing it'll be 50 years
since that discovery two years from now
i was a young anthropologist i was
searching in the extreme northeast of
ethiopia for looking for remains of our
human ancestors i glanced over my
shoulder one day i saw a little piece of
bone recognized as belonging to a human
skeleton and it led to lucy and lucy has
become the benchmark by which all
discoveries are judged that's amazing
just to see over the shoulder like how
did you pick the small piece of bone out
from from all around you well you know
you when you're out there you train your
eye and you know how you always say you
look
you find something in the last place you
look well
that's sort of like what happened oh my
god i carry these images in my mind of
bones and teeth and so on and when i saw
that elbow piece of elbow i knew it
couldn't be from a baboon it couldn't be
from an antelope and from all the work i
had done in graduate school i knew that
it had to come from a human ancestor and
why did you name her after the beetle
song well i thought it was a female
because of the very small size of the
bones and we thought well this is a
child no the third molars were erupted
the wisdom teeth as we call them today
and that night in camp in the middle of
nowhere when we were celebrating her
discovery someone was we were listening
to a beatles tape sergeant pepper's
lonely hearts club band and the song
lucy in the sky with diamonds was
playing and someone said
why don't you just call her lucy and
that was it you could not go back and
call her anything else
and now i you just told me that this was
your first launch and it gave you
goosebumps that's so wonderful i mean
how was it to know that there's a
spacecraft on there that's named after
the fossil you discovered well i will
never look at jupiter the same
jupiter was always interesting to me as
a kid i had my little telescope i
watched the moons go around jupiter and
to be out here this morning was
absolutely mind expanding and it was
such a positive experience you know the
world is going through some tribulations
something as positive as like this as
positive as as this is people should
look at and see what the creativity of
the human mind can do yeah and there it
is she's on her way yeah i'm so glad
so much yes and i i just said goosebumps
yeah perfect thank you so much for being
here i appreciate it why don't we send
it back over to joshua and mick for
another update on lucy hey thanks so
much megan
unfortunately we didn't quite fly over
ethiopia we did fly over part of
southern africa
on our way there and we're in the middle
now of the second burn of the centaur
mick talk to us about what the second
burn is so main engine start did occur
uh just a few minutes ago and this will
get uh centaur and lucy into its
transfer orbit leaving the park orbit
around earth heading into that orbit
heading uh to get lucy on her way to the
trojan asteroids so very important burn
this will last about six minutes uh and
to get her the velocity and everything
she needs to go to get on her way to uh
to to the trojan asteroids there you go
so just under about four minutes left in
this burn
so going back today we did kick off at
534 on the button uh and got a report
pressures
during the burn
uh from the storage bottle pressures
look good
from the ula commentator rob kesselman
uh ula always expecting excellence but
he reported that it the booster
performed better than expected i'm not
sure what's better than excellent but
they got it today yeah it just means we
had some great performance from the
first stage booster in the rd-180
putting centaur into the proper orbit uh
and that injection that they needed uh
for for getting lucy on her way and now
that we're into main engine start two uh
that just means we have a more precise
trajectory and everything's looking good
the spacecraft customer and ula and
launch services provider
program are very happy at this point
yeah so lucy after this burn is
completed we'll then wait a few more
minutes before we get into uh separation
from the centaur and at that point lucy
will be set up for her first orbit her
first major orbit of earth which will be
just
just under one year uh to complete and
then have the first earth gravity assist
flyby where lucy will get close enough
to earth where uh she'll literally just
be sl it'll it's like a slingshot effect
where she will just pick up speed flying
past earth to start getting out towards
where the uh the asteroid belt and the
trojan asteroids are yeah first of three
that's right so it'll it'll be a big
move for her that's right and so uh kind
of again thinking about the complexity
of this it's a little bit shocking to
think about the first asteroid
won't be explored won't be passed by for
another four years
and then beyond that there's another
gravity assist later on down the ride
after a few uh trojan asteroids being
explored
yeah 12 year mission very excited about
this we just started this this morning
right and uh the team did a great job uh
you know developing this trajectory and
making sure that we could get out to
those lagrange points that needed where
those asteroids are is it lagrange or
lagrange
i think depending upon what part of
america or the part of the world you're
from it could be a different different
pronunciation you know daryl reminds me
all the time it's lagrange but if you're
from the south it's probably something
else i don't know but lagrange points
where the uh where the trojan asteroids
are in l4 and l5
and you know that's that's a very
important i mean this team did an
excellent job in this trajectory design
and centaur is on target to deliver lucy
on that uh that path yeah so the
lagrange points a little explanation
there so for every pair of planetary
bodies that are interacting that are
kind of engaged
there are five lagrange points
and those five lagrange points are in
very consistent places and what that
means is that a lot of people have this
notion that if you're in low earth orbit
the space station for instance that you
are in zero gravity this is actually a
misconception you're in what we call
microgravity yes uh and so
as you're uh in orbit you're essentially
falling around the earth uh and so
gravity is still about 98 of what it is
right here now uh and so when you're at
a la garage point there's actually a
balance of gravitational forces where
you're able to essentially sit there and
what really is a zero gravity uh that's
probably a more appropriate place to
describe zero gravity uh again you
mentioned lagarange points four and five
uh that's where these two groups of
trojan asteroids hang out uh and these
are actually nowhere near jupiter uh so
they're jupiter's
they're jupiters sorry we're getting
calls here uh good performance here on
the centaur still as they're about to
wrap up this uh
this second burn again preparing for
spacecraft
and we have beaker too
that's a good sign right there main
engine cut off two that means uh centaur
has done its job performed
and uh 100 will be uh
coasting for just a few minutes as we
get ready for spacecraft separation
centaur make sure she's pointing the
right direction that's right uh and so
just finishing that thought the lagrange
points four and five are roughly
equidistant uh from the the sun and
jupiter making isosceles or equilateral
triangles uh if you've if you're ready
for your math at 6am uh or whatever time
it is right now uh we're we're watching
our our mission clock here uh and so
essentially they're the same distance
from jupiter as jupiter is from the sun
which is roughly 465 million miles so
these points are very far from jupiter
very far from the sun but pretty
exciting and and mick uh lsp no stranger
to exploring the solar system no
stranger to mission success with science
missions yeah you know we are very happy
to be working with united launch
alliance our commercial partner today
with this atlas 5 401 uh you know this
mission started seven years ago for some
of these folks uh some longer and as uh
the atlas 5401 was selected for this
mission lsp took all those requirements
from our spacecraft customer and uh we
looked at those and we decided what
needed to be done and we selected the
atlas 5 for this mission our in team of
engineers scientists and analysts
worked very closely with the spacecraft
customer and united launch alliance and
as a result we had a successful liftoff
at 5 34 a.m today at the very beginning
of our window in the beginning of our
science period
so very happy so far still waiting for
that spacecraft separation and making
sure the spacecraft's healthy healthy
but so far everything has been going
just as we had predicted
yeah very good a reminder coming up
ahead we have spacecraft separation
as you say there a countdown to when
we're expecting to see that happen uh
what you're seeing on screen is a
graphical representation based on real
telemetry data so we believe this is we
are confident this is what's happening
in space right now that's not actually a
live video stabilized at the coast
attitude
uh and so again on your time we're
expecting that spacecraft separation in
about nine minutes from now so uh after
that uh we will have a brief period
where we'll be we'll wait to start solar
ray deploy then we'll have that takes
about 20 minutes to deploy the solar
rays big beautiful solar rays and then
we will once those are up and powered we
would expect a couple minutes later to
be able to get that acquisition signal
that's a very scary time for the
spacecraft team they'll be waiting for
that for sure yeah absolutely all right
i think we are ready now to send you uh
upstairs uh to nasa edges franklin with
the lucy program manager
thanks guys yes i'm here with uh donut
douglas bradshaw who is the lucy project
manager donya how you doing today i'm
doing awesome great um
how do you prepare for a mission like
lucy when nothing quite like this has
been done before
well it certainly takes a team of
engineers uh scientists
uh everyone uh you know dr hal levinson
who is the lucy pi
has a vision
and it takes a team of hundreds to bring
that vision to fruition
how long have you
been working on this project
so i joined lucy about three years ago i
joined the team as the deputy project
manager and then about two years ago
became the project manager
now
do you have any like
exciting stories to tell about this
mission because you know you all had to
work through covet to get this thing up
and running yeah it uh you know cove it
happened in march 2020 unexpectedly and
um there was a lot of uncertainty around
that and um but
this team
and this spacecraft development led by
lockheed martin um quickly rapidly
without missing a beat put together a
plan to enable us to um
re-engineer the the integration and test
program
i know with within like the last two
years the
uh components for the spacecraft were uh
you know compiled but it wasn't even put
together how did you get that all up and
running basically
in a little over a year yeah so i mean
the the plan you're right when when the
pandemic happened we were about six five
or six months away from the start of our
spacecraft integration and test program
um and so there was a lot of uncertainty
uh but the team the entire team came
together
and really devised a way to
keep people safe
do social distinct social distancing
adding the capability for folks to
monitor
the integration and testing remotely
using collaboration tools online tools
just different techniques that were
available to us and so we were able to
do that certainly there were some
inefficiencies
but we were able to compress our
schedule so that we could stick to this
launch date
great dania thanks for joining us this
morning uh and continued success thank
you very much all right daryl back to
you all right franklin and donya thank
you so much
earlier you heard a little bit about the
lagrange points i got a primer from mick
and joshua and so now
let's revisit that lagrange points are
two gravitationally protected zones that
are around the orbit of jupiter here's
principal investigator hal levison and
lucy to help explain
the trojan asteroids are found in
lagrange points which are these special
places that leader follow planet in its
orbit by 60 degrees and it's sort of
where
the gravitational force of the planet
and the gravitational force of the sun
all cancel out so if you put an object
there it will stay there for a long
period of time basically forever so when
we see objects there
these are objects that we know were in
place a very long time ago
so if you just take a random asteroid
and just put it in the outer solar
system the gravitational force of the
four gynoplanics will just clear them
out in a very short period of time so
they'll basically be gone so the only
places it turns out
in the outer solar system where you can
find stable regions are these lagrange
points lucy in particular is going to go
after
the jupiter trojans we're trying to see
a type of object that represents
and constrains the formation of the
outer planets
and
you need to go to these lagrange points
in order to see that kind of hybrid
one of the really groovy aspects
of our mission is its trajectory because
we're visiting a record number of
objects like these trojans
and we do that with this very
complicated dance particularly in the
beginning where we are using the earth
actually as a gravitational slingshot so
lucy will start off in an orbit very
similar to the earth and then
gravitational encounters with the earth
will actually pump it up so it gets out
to the lagrange points near jupiter's
orbit
so if you're going to understand how
planets like the earth form
you have to understand how the bigger
planets which sort of dominated the
whole process
came to be and that's what lucy is going
to do
well that was how on tape let's join hal
live now who is with blair from nasa
edge guys take it away
thanks so much daryl
hal obviously an incredible launch
you've been very involved and very
important to the lucy mentioned but tell
us about the experience of being on
console and seeing the launch this
morning it was one of the most exciting
experiences of my life it was
uh truly awesome in the old fashioned
uh meaning of that word right well i
mean you've carried this mission for so
long so seeing this happen
what a great moment not just for you but
for the whole team well it's been a team
effort there's no doubt don you talked a
lot about how
it took a really village to build this
spacecraft right and
under some very difficult um conditions
so
um
i'm sorry
no it's an emotional moment i mean this
is a big deal it is and it's been all
the last 24 hours has just been a roller
coaster of excitement and build up
and everything was a success
tell us a little bit about your history
with with lucy how did it all start for
you
oh we started this project back in 2014
i think the first email that i have that
had the word lucy in the subject was in
march of that year and we've been
working and competing against other
missions since then
it's been a
haul and you know the amazing thing
about doing something like this
is that it was all paper and powerpoint
until about a year and a half ago and
then the folks at lockheed took these
concepts and built a spacecraft and you
know what's amazing too is you had a
very interesting window you really
needed to launch today or you'd have to
wait a long time before you could try
again well we have a spectacular
trajectory i think you've been talking
about that all day we're going
passed an amazing collection of objects
and um
we have one chance really to do this uh
the planets are literally aligning in
order to make uh this trajectory
happening happen so we either launch
today
or a year from now we do an ega an earth
gravity assist we could launch directly
at that time too so we had two chances
and luckily we got it off and it's
it's going and you were able to actually
you were on console but you came up and
actually saw the launch personally i was
not going to miss that right it's like
witnessing a birth of a child right you
just
really had to see it and now you watch
the child being raised that's right
right i mean
the the analogy of pregnancy and then a
birth and then raising a child is really
good for what we've been going through
here
great metaphor thanks so much hal we
really are excited for you in the lucy
mission back to you guys go lucy
hey yeah go lucy indeed uh we're
standing by for double check in just 30
seconds we're continuing to hear those
calls that we are on
so obviously a big moment especially for
the for the ula team this would be the
end of their their is now spinning up in
anticipation of spacecraft separation
15 seconds
huge moment here for all the teams
actually a successful launch that's what
it's all about
spacecraft set we have indication of
successful separation of the lucy
spacecraft so we're hearing some
clapping here in the in the mdc here at
the a soccer joshua
and that is a that is a huge moment for
all of the teams we still have quite a
bit to go uh solar ray deployment we
talked about those earlier those big
huge solar arrays that are needed and uh
the team spacecraft team will be
awaiting uh to to get confirmation that
that has started and then there'll be 22
minutes what they refer to as 22 minutes
of terror um waiting for those solar
rays to deploy and of course they have
to get acquisition of signal to verify
all that uh slightly after that so the
next few minutes as we get through this
is going to be a spacecraft team will be
kind of sitting around waiting to see
what happens and making sure lucy is uh
healthy and doing well but spacecraft
separation huge milestone for the teams
working the launch vehicle today yeah i
mean mick i mean even here uh i got some
goosebumps like it's chills in that
moment of just like you can feel the
energy of the people around you just
like so excited and obviously uh that
applause is very genuine uh this is a
heart this is a serious moment but it's
also like a really joyous moment um and
you'll see uh the ula team obviously
this is the end of their major task for
today
but nasa launch manager and the nasa lsp
team they will continue to stay with us
because uh for you guys getting the
spacecraft healthy is the mission it's
not just the launch it's making sure
that they get on their way successfully
that's correct we want to deliver
mission success as dr z talked about
earlier in the show right one of the
things we want here at nasa is mission
success and that's all the way through
making sure our spacecraft customer
knows what's going on with their
spacecraft and and everything is well so
we'll be standing around waiting for
solo raid deployment uh that'll begin uh
here about four minutes after the uh uh
you know about an hour and four minutes
after launch about six minutes from now
and uh we'll uh we'll go from there yeah
so again it's going to be a process that
will start at roughly l plus 104 30 and
then from there we will wait about 22
minutes is the expected time to complete
solar array deploy those 24 foot
diameter beautiful solar rays taking up
most of the size the the the physical
length of the the spacecraft uh and then
we will actually get confirmation of
that for a couple more minutes uh
because those are designed to power the
spacecraft uh all the way through its
mission and so there will be a couple of
minutes where the the communication is
being established between the spacecraft
and the ground uh not a simple process
we'll talk that in a few more minutes uh
once we get closer to to that
acquisition of signal moment milestone
uh we'll kind of talk through how we're
doing interaction i think i know there's
a chance we could potentially pick up uh
the actual live video uh it wouldn't be
live at the moment the actual video from
spacecraft separation if we do catch
that we'll bring you that um yeah ula
recorded that on board and as they get
closer to their download point they'll
be able to download that i don't know if
we'll get that right away or not but it
was recorded and eventually that will be
shared with the spacecraft customer uh
another unique thing you were taught we
were talking about those solar arrays
why it's so important is i heard earlier
today that you know those things
generate about 5 000 watts that's all
that the spacecraft uses i mean that's
not even enough to run a microwave here
right so
that just shows you how efficient the
spacecraft is yeah very good getting a
few views there from around the country
we had one from ula uh headquarters in
uh colorado that there in hangar ae with
some spacecraft folks uh but for now
daryl we're gonna send it back to you
i'm sorry to marie
all right thank you joshua time to catch
back up with our lucy cartoon character
and in this next episode lucy wants to
show you where she's going and why she's
studying the trojan asteroids
you might be wondering
where is lucy off to
ah yes the trojan asteroids these are a
population of asteroids in orbit around
the sun about as far away as jupiter
it may seem far away to you but our lucy
spacecraft is a capable explorer and
ready to make the trek to her targets
lucy is aiming to visit asteroids in
both of these trojan swarms on her
12-year mission the pull of gravity from
the sun balances the pull from jupiter
to keep the trojan asteroids in these
two groups
due to the gravitational balancing act
these asteroids have been in these
orbits for billions of years it's still
quite the challenge to explore these
targets
however our intrepid explorer is ready
for her mission aren't you lucy
ah of course you'll be the first
spacecraft to visit these asteroids i
can't help but wonder though why choose
these asteroids in particular
i see
the scientific evidence says the trojan
asteroids are leftover material from the
formation of the planets
right
these asteroids hold vital clues to
understanding the history of our solar
system
it's
just like a treasure hunt
what you discover could teach us about
the history of the solar system and how
the planets including earth came to be
the way they are
[Music]
i won't hold you up any longer
safe travels on your journey
be sure to write home and tell us all
about it
[Music]
welcome back out here to the broadcast
area and now we'd like to introduce you
to a special guest audrey martin she's a
graduate student at northern arizona
university and played a role in today's
launch audrey you're a student and you
were involved with the lucy science team
how unique is that it's incredibly
unique i feel very
very privileged to
have been able to
work with the science team and also be
here for the launch it's
it's absolutely amazing what
specifically did you work on i have been
working with the science team so i do
surface composition
spectral analysis stuff and i've been
working with the surface composition
working group to really understand
everything that we can understand now
about the surface of trojan asteroids so
that when we get there we can learn even
more and we can be really prepared for
what we're going to see and what we're
going to discover you've seen the
successful launch we all watched it here
that was pretty cool yeah we just saw
successful spacecraft separation but now
we're entering that that tense moment
where lucy's unfurling those gigantic
solar arrays
what's that like for you right now
i mean i'm um
very optimistic so far everything
that has gotten in the way of lucy and
the success of the mission um everyone
has come together in a very
collaborative way to overcome that and
so
i'm
very destiny yeah i'm very optimistic
and i think i think it'll go really well
and it will
and if other
if other students want to do something
similar how how do other students team
up with nasa like you did yeah great
question um so there's this program that
the lucy mission has um put together um
with arizona state university it's
called le space l apostrophe space how
fitting yeah it's perfect super cute um
and it's for undergraduate students who
are interested in working with nasa and
working
as a team and understanding or working
on you know designing missions and stuff
like that
that is really exciting and it's new
it's something that i didn't get to
experience in undergrad and i would have
absolutely loved it um so if anyone out
there is interested in it you should
definitely
look up um the little space program all
right thank you so much audrey thanks
for being here all right very good and
as you look at the bottom of the screen
there you can keep track as we are
watching solar array deploy you can see
the timer is at 20 minutes and counting
down and we of course are monitoring the
spacecraft team to find out the latest
now let's get back to that cartoon lucy
right she's kind of a hit yes and in the
next episode uh we hear from lucy's
flight navigator who discusses how the
team directs lucy on its journey to the
trojan asteroids
so to steer a spacecraft from millions
of miles away we have to first track its
trajectory so we have to determine where
in the solar system the spacecraft is
predict where it's heading and compare
that to where we want it to go so the
navigation team ensures lucy's on the
right trajectory by tracking lucy's
position and velocity in the solar
system predicting where it's headed and
adjusting its course so that it aces the
flyby
so once lucy starts approaching one of
its asteroid targets the navigation team
utilizes the instruments the cameras on
board to take pictures of the asteroid
and background stars and that helps us
hone in on targeting this close flyby
so commands travel at the speed of light
and over the course of lucy's trajectory
its position from earth is varying
substantially when lucy is near earth
during our earth gravity assists it
takes a mere seconds for the data our
commands to
be received by the spacecraft and for
the spacecraft to send data back to us
but at the farthest of lucy's trajectory
and the farthest distance from earth it
can take up to an hour for our commands
to be received traveling at the speed of
light
it's not only the data encoded in the
signals but it's the properties of the
signals itself
we know what time the spacecraft sent
the data and we know what time it was
received on earth so we can calculate
how long it took the signal to travel at
the speed of light and that gives us
information about how far lucy is from
earth
and then we also can get velocity
information because the spacecraft is
moving away from the earth as it's
sending those signals and so there's a
change in the frequency of the sig radio
signal and that gives us information
about velocity
so like all nasa missions lucy is
designed to be robust to anomalies or
surprises but in the event that
something unexpected happens there's
either a contingency plan on the shelf
or a group of relevant mission experts
are brought in to come up with the best
solution to solve the problem
a little less than six years from now
lucy will fly by the first trojan
asteroids in the mission eurybites and
its small moon keta this next episode of
the lucy cartoon series shows us an
illustration
there it is lucy
your first trojan asteroids
euripides with its small moon ketta
earth to lucy
remember you need to take a lot of
images of euripides and keta in not a
lot of time before you're zooming off to
your next target
make sure you get all those images for
us
[Music]
it's beautiful isn't it
and we're past
that was quick right
get any good data
that's great to hear
can't wait to see them just send them
back to us here at earth
[Music]
we have so much to learn from what
you've already sent back to us and
you're just getting started out there
so remember it will take lucy 12 years
to visit all eight asteroids on her
journey and the next group of trojan
asteroids lucy will visit each has its
own unique characteristics and lessons
to reveal
there's still five more trojan asteroids
to explore on your 12-year journey each
one has a different story to tell about
the history of our solar system
next up is poly a near 21 kilometers or
13 miles in diameter
afterwards you'll be zooming by lucas
which rotates at an extremely slow rate
with each day being about 18.5 earth
days long
afterwards you'll be on to aurus which
might be rich in organics and carbon
lastly you'll be on your way to a twin
pair of asteroids patroclus and meniscus
these asteroids relatively unchanged
over 4 billion years will give us a
glimpse of our solar system's distant
past
with each flyby of a trojan asteroid
you'll be looking at time capsules from
the birth of our solar system over 4
billion years ago
lucy what your observations tell us
about the composition and properties of
the trojan asteroids could give us clues
about how earth came to be
absolutely
carry on your journey lucy and don't
forget to call and show us what you find
out there we'll be waiting good luck
thank you lucy the trojan asteroids have
been called ancient time capsules so you
know what we've got a challenge for you
to create your own time capsule to open
when lucy completes the mission in 12
years here's how you can get involved
march 2nd 2033 where will you be
the lucy spacecraft will be right here
but what about you
over the next 12 years nasa's lucy
mission will explore more asteroids than
any previous mission flying by one main
belt asteroid and seven trojan asteroids
these ancient time capsules will allow
us to trace the origins of our solar
system
we invite you to accompany lucy on its
12-year journey by creating your own
time capsule set aside a box of mementos
create a digital file or simply write a
letter to yourself get creative we
encourage you to post a photo drawing
video or other description on social
media using the hashtag lucy time
capsule at each major mission milestone
we'll remind you to revisit and add to
your time capsule consider what would
you tell your future self in what ways
will you grow how do you want to mark
this current moment in your life
lucy carries her own time capsule into
space
a plaque with words of wisdom for our
descendants who may one day come across
the spacecraft long after its primary
mission ends
the messages encourage hope and humility
knowledge and curiosity appreciation of
humanity and exploration of the cosmos
we hope you'll join us and lucy as we
look with anticipation upon the unknown
of our future
both as individuals and as humankind
and remember to use the hashtag lucytime
capsule when you are sharing your videos
and photos on social media and we can't
wait to see what you come up with and
what marie comes up with what's here i i
heard about this project and i got so
excited so i came prepared with my own
little time capsule items i have a
picture of my kids they're both under
six so they're going to look so much
different when lucy gets done in 12
years they might not like me as much
then either but
so we got to remember this moment i've
got that one of their favorite toys a
unicorn some some patches from missions
this year the crew 2 one they launched
earlier this year and the lucy mission
patch of course a pair of my kids shoes
because i'm sentimental a mask
because it's a face mask i mean it will
remember the times and my first plane
tickets from my first post-quarantine
trip on an airplane
how about you daryl what do you have
well i don't have all that but you know
what i wore some socks that are my plans
you wore socks you see that i mean we
don't want to show that
he's taking off i'm going to take off
but this is great because you know why
that's jupiter on my sock right all
right well and so on the other side
what's that marie i don't know maybe
some asteroids looks like your ribbities
maybe you know but you know what i was
going to share this with you but you
just took that off your foot so you can
get your own time capsule box
i can't put it in the little girl's shoe
right you can put it in my baby shoe
sure yeah right
all right and we have first light right
behind us you can start to see uh
sunrise hasn't happened yet this is just
beautiful this is a beautiful view this
is the kennedy turn basin where we
brought in the shuttle main external
tank and also uh brought in the core
stage for the artemis uh mission and uh
that's gonna be a great one yeah so much
coming up here on the space coast uh we
heard a little earlier from lucy's
project manager now here's a recap in
her own words about the work it took to
get lucy into the sky
the lucy mission is a planetary mission
to
the trojan asteroids that are around
jupiter it's going to survey
actually a total of eight targets seven
asteroids around jupiter and one
asteroid in the main asteroid belt once
you know where you're going and the type
of science that you want to take one of
the things that you start looking at is
the spacecraft
what size spacecraft where is it going
how much power does it need to carry
does it need solar rays what type of
solar rays what type of vehicle it's
going to be used to launch it in the
space
so that dictates how much mass you can
carry and one things i do as a project
manager is to assemble a team of
scientists and engineers and technicians
and business people to design that
overall spacecraft to achieve your
mission
in designing the spacecraft you are
always thinking about what type of
environment is it going to be subjected
to is it going to orbit around earth is
it going into deep space is it going to
mars is it going close to the sun and so
as engineers one of the things that
you're thinking about very early on is
how can you design this system and test
the system in order to verify and
convince yourself that it's going to
survive in space and as part of that it
goes through a very rigorous test
program and so we call it
shaking and baking and so we actually
put it through what we call a thermal
vac chamber in which we simulate the
space environment we also put it on what
we call a vibe table in which we vibrate
it so we shake it and one of the
important things that you have to do in
order to be convinced that it's going to
survive is to make sure that the
environment in which you're testing it
in the simulate environment
is harsher than what it's going to see
in space so once you subject that
spacecraft or that instrument to that
environment then you can have confidence
that it's going to last the lifetime
that it's been designed for
all right thank you very much ladies as
you can see at the bottom of your screen
we are counting down to confirmation of
solar ray deploy and acquisition of
signal just about eight minutes to go in
that now many of nasa's unique science
missions have one thing in common and
that is the launch services program that
helps each mission take flight lsp is
the common thread
[Music]
since the dawn of humanity
we have looked to the stars and dreamed
of bridging the gap between the earth
and the cosmos
[Music]
in the 20th century
nasa turned that dream into a reality by
launching humanity into a bold era of
scientific discovery
as pioneers of space travel our best and
brightest designed and built everything
from the ground up from launch pads to
rockets all of which were government
owned and operated
as nasa's science and robotics evolved
we encouraged a competitive launch
market to develop ushering in a new way
to explore and discover through
commercial space flight spacecraft
customers from around the world all with
the same desire reached out to find an
expert at nasa for support
thus nasa's launch services program was
born
[Music]
our mission is to centralize nasa's
launch services and address
state-of-the-art customer needs when
placing their spacecraft in orbit around
the earth the sun or destinations deeper
into the solar system
the lsp family is made up of a diverse
tapestry of government and contractor
engineers analysts operation experts and
business advisors all united by a common
goal
to get your spacecraft off the ground on
time on budget and successfully to its
final destination wherever that may be
we match scientific and robotic
spacecraft with the appropriate rocket
and certify rocket performance and
reliability
we support full-service missions
advisory services and one-of-a-kind
contracts
the launch services program is the
common thread that bridges the
spacecraft organization to the rocket
designer
and the spacecraft to the rocket
we provide long-term technical
leadership and expertise from
pre-mission planning
to system verification and validation
all the way through launch
whatever the vision or requirements our
team will be there guiding our customers
every step of the way on their journey
through space
we are the common thread that connects
the science world to the physical world
by putting the necessary instruments in
place
the thread that weaves nasa's
industry-leading knowledge and support
into the fabric of the commercial space
market
we unite customers capabilities and
culture to explore space through
unparalleled launch services
[Music]
nasa's launch services program we are
earth's bridge to space
[Music]
all right we are now at launch plus one
hour 21 minutes and just under five
minutes away uh from what we hope will
be
acquisition of signal we're still inside
that 22 minutes of terror when we don't
know that yet that's why i say we hope
we'll find out
in about four minutes now we will be
checking in with the launch team in just
a minute but before we do that nasa's
launch services program has a really
busy rest of 2021 planned here's a
preview of what's ahead
since 1998 nasa's launch services
program or lsp has served as earth's
bridge to space
based at nasa's kennedy space center in
florida the program matches scientific
and robotic spacecraft with launch
vehicles for some of america's most
inspiring space missions
our mission to successfully place
spacecraft in orbit around the earth the
sun and destinations deeper into the
solar system
we centralize nasa's launch services
while addressing state-of-the-art
customer needs
but lsp does more than pair spacecraft
with the appropriate rocket the diverse
group of government and contractor
engineers analysts and advisors certify
rocket performance and reliability
the team provides long-term technical
expertise and support to spacecraft
customers from around the
world the team manages launches from
multiple sites depending on customer and
mission needs cape canaveral space force
station in florida vandenberg space
force base in california
reagan test site at kwajalein atoll in
the republic of the marshall islands and
the pacific spaceport complex in kodiak
alaska
building off of past success lsp forges
ahead to support nasa's future lucy will
be the first mission to study jupiter's
trojan asteroids which may be remnants
of the primordial material that formed
the outer planets of our solar system
it's then back to the west coast for
double asteroid redirection test or dart
nasa's first planetary defense mission
that will be followed by imaging x-ray
polarimetry explorer or xp launching
from kennedy
xp will expand our understanding of
x-ray production in objects such as
neutron stars and black holes
years of testing determination and
dedication working as one
nasa's launch services program is
earth's bridge to space
all right just about two and a half
minutes until we hopefully finish solar
array deployed two minutes after that
we're expecting to get the acquisition
of signal as we dawn here the beautiful
shot behind us marie of uh the sun
getting ready to rise here at the
kennedy space center the kennedy turn
basin behind us what a beautiful sight
yeah storybook picture behind us uh and
as you saw in that video the next
mission for nasa's launch services
program is the double asteroid
redirection test we call that dart um
that's currently scheduled to lift off
november 23rd i think it's uh
thanksgiving eve uh over on the west
coast vandenberg space force base so
we're really excited for that one and
more uh details you can find on that at
nasa.gov forward slash dart
and so while we stand by to find out
more information about the situation
with lucy we want to say hey this is a
long journey ahead of her but these
moments right here are very critical
especially that confirming of that solar
array deploy so let's toss it over to
joshua and mick over at the asoc who
will talk us through it guys
yeah thanks daryl uh man what an
exciting year ahead uh obviously we'd
love to talk about that but we need to
focus on what's at hand uh one minute
left again this is the anticipated time
to complete the solar ray deploy uh nick
i think we did hear that there is a good
call on beginning that process
yeah the team is getting some low rate
data and we did hear from the spacecraft
project that they had begun that project
on time so as you said we're hoping here
in about 50 seconds to hear that solar
array deploy is complete and as daryl
mentioned two minutes after that we get
full acquisition signal to check out the
uh health of lucy and we should hear
that uh come in from
spacecraft project manager to our nasa
launch manager
to make sure that lucy is is good
yeah we we did get that call we weren't
sure if we would hear a call for
beginning solar array deploy because we
were we did kind of i don't know i don't
say lucked out because there's no luck
here but we were fortunate to get that
low rate data we may not get full
confirmation until we do get that
acquisition of signal which although
that clock is almost at zero may not be
for a couple more minutes
as we wait here mick
communicating back to earth is a
challenge and we kind of saw a little
bit about that from one of our guests
talking about when you're close to earth
it's speed of light uh but ultimately
it's always speed of light but that's a
lot easier when you're close to earth
there's different communication
mechanisms yeah so for today's mission
we actually utilized the tdrs network
the telemetry data relay satellite
network that nasa owns for the vehicle
telemetry and for some of the spacecraft
data that we've started
excuse me
and as lucy moves on its way out towards
the asteroids we'll take advantage of
the deep space network or the set of
ground stations here on earth that have
huge huge satellites that can pick up
the smallest and faintest sound from
space so that is a huge asset that we
have within the nasa and aerospace
industry to be able to work with
satellites that travel this far as as
lucy is doing yeah again hoping now
within a couple minutes to hear from
lucy i want to emphasize that just
because we if we don't hear that quickly
that's not necessarily a bad sign
there's a big window here when we know
that that acquisition of signal might
take place so uh we will kind of try and
stay with you as long as it makes sense
uh but again that's kind of the nature
of space flight again it's not about
luck it is it is about science and
there's lots of factors at play yeah
like i said earlier the team has done a
great job of designing the trajectory
and working and so far all the
predictions have been right on on target
so as the spacecraft team works through
their thing
there's their steps
there is this another 20 minutes roughly
that we could get signal or it could go
as late as uh you know hour 55 after
after uh liftoff so we'll stay around
and look at what's going on but the team
is definitely still looking at that and
working it
you know joshua i did want to go back
you had asked me earlier when we were
off air about spacecraft separation and
how simple that was and it was you know
basically it looks simple it looks
simple but it's very it's very uh it's
an engineering feat and it uses a marmon
clamp that's been around for years and
the marmon clamp has a has an explosive
bolt that is released and the marmon
clamp releases and lucy was actually
pushed off the front end of centaur with
six separation springs uh so that's
that's a you know it sounds very easy
but it's actually a cool it's actually a
very cool engineering design that allows
us to be able to keep the spacecraft on
there for the ride and then separate uh
where they need to go so i wanted to
bring that back for the folks on on uh
that are watching us i think that's just
a cool engineering thing uh that
happened in the mission today
yeah i appreciate those tuning in again
we had successful liftoff on time this
morning at 5 34 a.m eastern time and we
are standing by now hoping any second to
hear uh that lucy is alive and well uh
but as we we wait um thinking ahead to
what's to come lucy again headed to
eight asteroids around the solar system
one main asteroid belt uh and then seven
trojan asteroids
yeah and this is and this is just the
beginning as we've said earlier right
the team will get the solar rays out
they'll get acquisition signal they've
got a lot of work to do on orbit uh
testing out the systems making sure that
their batteries are charged making sure
everything's working as i mentioned
earlier you know they're very efficient
power usage 5000 watts so they want to
make sure all that's working as they're
traveling towards these asteroids so
that when they get there that everything
works in the sciences so they'll do
checkouts of all the instruments that we
talked about on the show today and the
team the spacecraft team still has a lot
of work over the next few months
and years 12 12 years right yeah so uh
that's that's that's what's up coming
for the spacecraft team um we just saw a
little bit ago you know we're still
focused on lucy but the lsp team
is beginning to work with our other
commercial partners on some missions uh
another asteroid mission dart uh which
is a cool i just think a very cool
mission that we're going to send a
spacecraft to an asteroid and try to
impact its trajectory a little bit so
that's that's looking forward to that
mission coming up here very soon so
yeah and uh
looking ahead to lucy's journey she's uh
if you're ever frustrated by your cell
phone not working in a timely fashion uh
and you're kind of anxious to hear us
get this call a reminder that lucy's now
hurtling away from earth at greater than
escape velocity which means more than 25
000 miles per hour away from earth so
this is this is much more complicated
than even a simple text message that you
just can't get to send
yeah no the teams the teams are
definitely paying attention uh looking
at all the uh the stuff they've got and
watching that the automation on the
spacecraft is working uh definitely uh
can tell you that there's probably a
little tense moments going on right now
from that aspect
but we are still waiting to hear
uh if we we hear around us some clapping
but i'm not sure what that's for yet um
but we are waiting to hear from the
spacecraft project manager to the nlm on
uh on acquisition of signal so
uh hopefully we'll hear that soon
from from the team
but definitely something is going on
there's some happy and clapping going on
here
i feel like i feel like i'm a little in
the dark right so that's right that's
good but we'll hear that hopefully very
soon from our nlm
so mick as we look ahead to uh to this
process again the speeds we're talking
about here pretty
uh exceptional um lucy will get up to a
maximum speed of about 400 000 miles per
hour uh a lot of that has to do with
these gravity assists that they'll
they'll get uh the slingshot effect from
earth uh hurtling towards the trojan
asteroids which are in the same orbit
that jupiter follows uh all right so i'm
seeing some of i'm seeing lots of
applause uh i'm hoping that's a good
time we haven't heard the the word come
in yet so um so yeah i just i just saw
some a movement that's all
right are completely deployed so that's
a good thing for the spacecraft team
solar rays are completely out and so now
we're just waiting on acquisition of
signal uh from the uh from the team and
you know joshua as we said um these
things uh they ran some analysis and
there was some time frame here and
they're within their time frame so not
not necessarily anything happen uh bad
here but it's uh going well so far for
the lucy spacecraft so we'll wait to
hear that they get that acquisition
signal and determine the final health of
uh the lucy spacecraft
yeah the uh the orbit that we're taking
is a very uh high elliptical uh where it
will come around uh near earth and then
slingshot out into the trojan asteroids
uh in the same orbit as jupiter so that
the apogee of that orbit uh would end up
being kind of the slowest point uh of of
lucy's motion and jupiter and the
trojans move at a speed of roughly 29
000 miles per hour in their orbit around
the sun so that kind of gives you a
sense of the incredible speed that you
have to build up so that at your slowest
point you're doing that um so again an
incredible
just uh trajectory and engineering feat
to be prepared to to rely on lucy to fly
freely for 12 years that's something
that a lot of people might have a
misconception about is that lucy's not
under powered flight for 12 years yeah
that's true i mean it's not like they
can change trajectory during this time
right we have put them on a uh where
they needed to be by the specific
designed trajectory it needs to be and
with those massive solar arrays out
there they can't make very many uh they
can't make any maneuvers out there so
lucy is on her way with solar rays
deployed
and things are going well so far we're
just still waiting to hear like i said
we keep hearing some clapping in the
background that we know that some of
that is solar ray deployment and we're
just waiting to hear that they've
acquired signal of the spacecraft and uh
we'll go from there
yeah and it's
it's looking like that word is in i
noticed there the folks in in that room
that you're seeing on screen have taken
off their headsets that is usually a
sign that we are good to go here
so uh i believe we're we're good we're
gonna send this out to daryl now um so
mick that's gonna do it for you and me
here appreciate you riding along with me
mick uh until next time yeah joshua
thank you this was an exciting mission
very happy for the spacecraft team so
far and the launch
lsp and united launch alliance teams
looking forward to our next mission dart
awesome signing off from the asoc daryl
back to you thank you joshua mick and in
the upper right hand part of that
picture it was nice to see how leveson
and donya douglas bradshaw celebrating
the big moment of acquisition of signal
yeah finally able to breathe a sigh of
relief
uh and now here's a special preview of
nasa's next launch services program
science mission launching next month
it's the double asteroid redirection
test
[Music]
so
[Applause]
looking forward to the dart mission got
to make those travel plans out to
california we'll have it for you here on
nasa tv for now though we want to go
back to the nasa launch manager and he
is with our own franklin fitzgerald
yes i'm here with omar baez who's the
senior launch director for the lucy
mission
omar
how did things go this morning
things were splendid today everything
went on time
as predicted and uh i couldn't ask for
for a better count it uh just clicked
off the way it should
um and uh we
really worked no major issues so we were
able to hit the window at the very
beginning on the very first day
of the short window
for lucy so we're we're happy to be here
at this point i understand you were
wrapping up a few things before you were
able to come up um everybody just got up
and left what does that mean that means
things are really good so what that
means is both uh
solar arrays have deployed and we did
lock onto the acquisition
signal
from the spacecraft so
the
folks at goddard and lockheed martin
denver are controlling now
and have positive control over the
spacecraft so
that's the best
shape you want to be in
right before you came on they wrote a
package talking about dark that's the
next mission for lsp can you tell us a
little bit more about it so that one is
so cool for us uh dart is going to
um kinetically hit
an asteroid
and uh it's our second
uh planetary mission from the west coast
or vandenberg so super exciting uh just
another a different way of
spotting an asteroid and this time we're
trying to to go in the aspect of not
studying it but
uh planetary defense could we move uh
an asteroid if we needed to and so this
is super cool and a whole different uh
way of operating for us so we love it
omar baez congratulations on a
successful launch and uh are you going
to be the launch director in uh i will
be the launch director for dart and
after dart we have exp from this coast
and that's going to be a cool one for
launch services program also because
it's our first
ksc launch
we're a program that's been at ksc for
23 years and we've never launched
anything from the kennedy space center
our very first from complex 39a oh
that's going to be awesome we'll be
there for that hopefully we'll have you
on the show then again as well okay
thanks for being with us today guys back
to you omar and franklin thank you and
as you look behind us you see the dawn
of a new day
and there is the dawn of lucy and her
journey to the trojan asteroids seems
very fitting yeah what a nice tribute
from mother earth to lucy the fossil and
the spacecraft now about to uncover uh
secrets of our beginnings indeed so
we're going to leave you with a replay
of this morning's liftoff
and you can also follow along live
mission updates online at nasa.gov
forward slash lucy have a great weekend
and keep looking up
that's my line
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
zero
liftoff atlas 5 takes flight sending
lucy to uncover the fossils of our solar
system
utilization
you